let's watch another episode of strange
addictions huge thank you to thrive
market for sponsoring this video let's
get started
i'm addicted to coffee enemas
for the past two years trina hasn't been
able to function without her daily
coffee enemas
a procedure where liquid is injected
into the colon to clean out the lower
intestine
her addiction is so intense she does up
to four every day okay let's just do it
right off the bat coffee enemas have not
been proven to help with any medical
condition in like the 60s 70s we used to
say maybe for constipation but that's
been dropped from medical literature we
have so many better ways of handling
constipation that this is largely
unnecessary they're saying coffee
animals are used to clean your colons no
they're not it's a self-cleansing part
of the body my initial reaction was
my god that's disgusting pretty
judgmental response i tried it
and now i'm addicted to coffee oh
two years ago trina turned to this
unconventional ritual after a series of
health issues
i had a lot of stomach problems
digestive problems problems with my
kidney my liver
i started to do research and it led me
into the coffee enemas
immediately i really started to feel the
benefit it's understandable someone that
is having symptoms who's struggling
looking to find answers online finds a
treatment that is within their grasp
something that they can do on their own
and tries it that doesn't mean it's the
right treatment or it's something that
most people should try my concern is
that there's something else going on in
these people's bodies that can be missed
and potentially get worse over time
because they're not seeing a doctor
problems with kidneys needs to be
investigated because if kidneys start
failing that's a threat to your own life
my name is julius i'm 62 years old
and i'm addicted to balloons i love
balloons
they're beautiful
they're soft smooth delicate i have a
connection with them is this like going
to be similar to what we've seen in the
previous episodes of like objectophilia
or even animism where you believe that
certain physical and
enamel inanimate objects have a soul or
spirit or maybe you become even sexually
attracted to them i'm curious now julius
has filled his home with over 50 000
balloons
unless he's surrounded by them my
favorite is the spherical ones
honestly i don't see what's wrong with
this yet he likes decorating his house
with balloons some people like painting
their walls i don't know they put
wallpaper on some people put paper on
their walls teach their own but julius's
obsession with balloons goes beyond
shapes and colors my love for balloons
it's also a sexual love
when i see a beautiful balloon my heart
starts to flutter and i get aroused
i'll take a 12 inch and i'll inflate it
to 11 inch
that way it can take a lot of abuse
there's a potential connection between
objectophilia atomism and autism that
one study tried to explore and i'm
interested in exploring that subject to
see how connected those two conditions
are my wife thinks it's strange but she
accepted
again like you have a job you have a
partner you live a good life you take
care of your health and you're sexually
attracted to balloons
not really a disorder disorders are
based on ability to perform life
functions get satisfaction in life reach
goals in life let them sit in his room
and blow up balloons and squeeze them
like
what's the why why is he even a thing on
this show it's kind of weird more power
to you sir back to the show in just a
second but first let me tell you about
thrive market an online marketplace
where you can save money and get amazing
products i've personally worked with
thrive market for years and we teamed up
again this april for earth month because
they sell thousands of my favorite
products from the best eco-friendly
brands like chomps amy's gaia herbs and
more everything they offer is either
ethically sourced sustainably farmed or
regeneratively grown so what you get is
better for you and the planet with
thrive market you can shop and sort by
the values that matter most to you fair
trade certified gluten-free vegan you
name it and all orders 49 or more are
shipped free and delivered with carbon
neutral shipping from their zero waste
warehouses small sustainable steps can
lead to a big impact and make positive
change for our climate and that's why i
use thrive market and i hope you do too
choose whatever membership best fits
your lifestyle one month or 12-month
packages for me the 12-month package at
just five dollars a month is really a
reasonable choice and that's the one i
recommend to my friends and family join
thrive market today and get 40 off your
first order and a free gift worth over
fifty dollars all you have to do is
visit the link down below thrive market
dot com slash dr mike remember doctors
spelled out all right let's get back to
the show i'm addicted to about
injections
[Music]
i'm curious if this is butt injections
through like a bbl where they do
liposuction then re-inject the fat
carmelo's had 54 butt injections yet
she's never bared her behind to a
plastic surgeon
she receives her shots on the black
market getting pumped with an
unregulated substance that's been known
to include metal lubricant and cement
yeah i mean that's really dangerous
there's so much that can go wrong here
this isn't a traditional bbl
even bbl's are dangerous like one in
three thousand individuals who has a bbl
has a complication of a fatty embolism
the fat actually gets lodged into their
blood vessels and can be lethal if it
travels all the way up to the lungs i've
actually had patients that have had huge
huge complications as a result of bad
injections like this they were done
abroad in other countries but then they
ended up getting a terrible cellulitis
abscess formation in the buttock area
where like major surgery had to take
place to take out the necrotic tissue
dead tissue so they ended up losing a
part of their buttock what brings you in
today dr yoon welcome back to the
channel do you have any idea what she
injected you with did she tell you he
had liquid silicone okay but i'm not
sure
if that's really what it was did she do
anything afterwards i mean did she
stitch up the incisions
she put superglue there are times we use
glue in medical settings in the er but
not for deep wounds not for big wounds
not for wounds that could potentially
become severely infected so like there's
a time and place for all medical tools
and that's not the place for super glue
you can see here this is your thigh the
fat in your thigh which is smooth and
normal but up here it looks kind of
spongy this texture and that's
definitely not normal
so even though you're healthy it just
takes one bad injection to literally
kill you
oh that's good i'm glad she was able to
decide not to do that again my name is
casey i'm 26 years old i'm from
fayetteville tennessee
and i'm addicted to carrying around my
husband's urn
their marriage was picture perfect until
shawn suffered a severe asthma attack
two months ago two months ago it's
recent why
why are they not letting this woman
believe in peace like her addiction has
recently evolved
i guess with the transfer of his
cremains you know some got into the
cardboard box as well and they spilled
out on my hands
and i didn't want to wipe wipe them off
because that's my husband i don't want
to wipe him away
um
so i just
licked it off my fingers infectious
disease wise it's her husband so very
low risk there and the body's been
cremated so all infectious diseases
would essentially be wiped out as well
it tastes like
rotten eggs sand and sandpaper
but i've grown to love that taste i
wonder if there's a pica condition here
happening i'm a little bit concerned
about
what's in embalming fluid and i'm a
little bit concerned about how much
of those chemicals are in those ashes oh
i did not know that that was the case if
there was embalming fluid used
formaldehyde is the main ingredient in
emboldening fluid and that is very
lethal i think one ounce of formaldehyde
can be lethal to your lungs throat
nervous system like there's a lot of
issues with that and then the other
ingredients in embalming fluid is like
methanol ethanol things that can lead to
blindness brain damage like that's a
really serious concern if you are trying
to deal with the reality of this and to
help yourself
i'm afraid that you're not going to be
able to as long as you're eating ashes
because you're eating a substance that
would make you lose touch with reality
i think that's probably ideal for own
safety at that point it definitely took
a turn from carrying her husband's ashes
which i find not to be a medical issue
to her consuming embalming fluid and
ashes that could become a medical issue
and it's something that threatens her
life and now now it's become a disorder
my name is margaret and i'm 53 years old
i live in morning view kentucky and i'm
addicted to stinging myself with bees
[Music]
what kind of means of the bee because
doesn't the bee die after it's sting
soothed margaret has been addicted to
bee stings for the past 10 years
it could be an endorphin rush because
when you do experience pain when your
body tries to relieve that pain it sends
endorphins to try and decrease the pain
her addiction started innocently as a
way to relieve her arthritis you know
there is um some preliminary evidence
weak evidence i would call it of b venom
helping individuals with rheumatoid and
osteoarthritis however when you compare
it to the treatments that we have now
you can get better outcomes with less
side effects and most importantly less
pain first time that i stung myself it
didn't hurt as bad as i thought it would
and it just got easier every time and
it's great that she doesn't have a b
allergy i mean some individuals they get
stung their whole arm blows up their
mouth can even blow up they can go into
anaphylaxis people carry epipens for
bees and you know even though allergies
are more likely to happen early in life
they can develop later in life as well
but every time margaret stings herself
the honeybee dies
something margaret is all too aware of
every bee is precious i get sad when i
watch him die i prefer to get an older
bee the younger bees they've got their
lives ahead of them and it helps me feel
less guilt about killing the bees
it's a sad situation to see because i
would love for her to find pain relief
in a way where it's not damaging to the
bees to her mental health and
potentially gives her can give her
longer lasting relief
depending on what the cause of her
arthritis is did you hear about the
japanese eyeball looking trend that's
right click here for my full video
talking all about it you're gonna learn
a lot thanks again to thrive market for
sponsoring this video join thrive market
today and get 40 of your first order and
a free gift worth over 50 use my link to
get started as always stay happy and
healthy